do you remember the first time someone
paid you to write oh god yeah my very
first paid assignment was an episode of
Saved by the Bell it's the saturday
morning TV show and it's a funny story
because the show had i think it was like
its second season the long x right when
i first started writing and I remember
ate my agent said well there's this show
it's a saturday morning kids show it's a
live-action show that you know they need
writers they like to writing writing
samples you want to go in and pinch and
I go well why you're sending in there i
want to write you know whatever it was
back there cheers or Murphy Brown or
what I want to want right one of those
just go no just go it'll be fun and
they'll probably hire you whatever so I
go in I pitched a ton of stories they
picked one they liked it and they shot
and they shot it and it was a nice
experience well on the size and just
first getting getting my first credit
and all of that that episode has rerun
50,000 times on one platform or another
the show became very successful it
became like this iconic show of its
period it went onto DVD and you know so
the episode is on all the dvds and to
this day i can i can write something
that is really successful and though and
the one thing somebody will say to me
when i tell them i wrote Saved by the
Bell I love that show I remember your
episode oh my god wait till I tell
so-and-so that you wrote that episode of
Saved by the Bell you know it's just
it's really funny so it turned out to be
a great first assignment you know that
little did I know but that was the first
time I was actually paid as a
screenwriter in which episode was I
wrote an episode called save the max
which was the best the kids unearthed
the old high school radio station that
they find in a basement or something and
they use it to create a telethon kind of
radios on to save their their diner the
max which is going to close because
they're going out of business or
something and yes and I was good and and
it's just funny to people just they know
it and they remember it it's like culty
almost you know so so you so I just say
if it makes sense take the job because
you never know it's going to come up
right it's going back to that first time
you know knowing that you did get the
job what was going through your head
like the night of the night out yeah
when you found sounds when I found
got the giant oh it was huge because you
know I had just started writing and and
I had been working a lot writing spec
scripts and going on meetings and things
like that and I had the job I had had I
was doing pretty well in it and and and
I just kind of figured when I left that
job well well you know I've gotten jobs
on you know it hasn't been that hard to
find jobs i'll i'll do this and I'll get
a job you know it is I wasn't prepared
for how difficult it was and maybe if I
was I wouldn't have done it so I just
went in like you know optimistic and and
you know full steam ahead so to get my
first writing job relatively soon after
I after I started you know the left at
other jobs and started writing it felt
like this was huge accomplishment and
and we're fun and I I didn't write a
second opus or any other episodes for
them but I just go up back in their
pitch a few times and and yeah it was it
was very exciting but you know what to
this day when somebody says yes or
something it's the greatest feeling you
know it's just it's so it's a validation
and you know you're just so proud of the
fact that you know you really came up
with an idea somebody liked it
somebody's gonna you know you can't get
it get to write it you know you can get
to tell your story you know it's always
exciting when you left that other job
did you have a specific plan in place
like okay I'm going to give myself this
much time if it doesn't work out then
here's Plan B for sure I never had a
plan B I've done except my family
started my sister after I left the job
and yeah after doing this for a few
years and you know it definitely had its
ups and downs she said to me well do you
have a plan B and I said no this is my
plan B I my plan a was the other job
then that didn't work out for me so just
my plan B actually became my plan a so
that's it and I always I just always
stuck it out I mean you know I always
you know I loved writing I never got the
don't quit your day job I got enough
work along the way to to know I should
keep doing it until things ultimately
became more consistent and I always did
other writing work to fill in in between
you know whether it's journalism work or
press kit writing or publicity arriving
or whatever are those writing something
so it in between all the script writing
just to sort of keep going and to make
money but you know I just never gave up
and I just always believed in the
possibility of success whatever level of
was you know I mean I think you have to
manage your expectation in terms of
where what your place maybe in the food
chain but you know I love writing
there's really not much outside I want
to do I'd love to you know be a chef I'd
love to be a psychiatrist I'm you know a
psychologist I mean I know lots of
things I'm interested in but you know
when it comes to you know to my passion
you know it's really writing
you